[music]
welcome to the museum für
naturkunde my name is carsten hugo
i come from the paul drude institute
leibniz institute for solid state
electronics here in berlin today
we are presenting our silence for the very first time
already now the
flowers are speaking three institutes will
compete against each other they  have produced a
clip and you, the live
audience in the hall and in the live stream,
will vote on which clip
convinced you the most the guests are
already here we
probably have christoph rath from the max
delbrück center for molecular pharmacology on stage
we have without serious from
leibniz  institute for crystal
cultivation and we have costs from the institute for water ecology and inland fisheries
musically accompanied by ingo günther
and our horst friedrich liechtenstein
should be here any moment nice
show starts
[music]
and now speaking flown i have
something prepared
yes
[music]
the
magical moments
now the flowers speak beautifully that
you are here tonight in the museum i
don't know yet but the museum since
i always at night if you can see before
today is about the beauty of the jubilation
for which beauty
a cry
these things that are beautiful  they yell at
us and say we are important we
are important we have the
kurhaus going under we have blood they
speak the language of flowers is
universal begins at birth for
birthday
love for wedding was terminally ill
eat when someone apologizes to us
because he  sometimes the flowers are
blooming the flowers the language of flowers
so the
doctor got gm he also played a
bit of the role here when we put
the things together
he was a bit afraid of the moment
they
used the words in a disgusting way
and someone else  Fetish of mine is
baking too full hb fuller one is the
seminar so an experimental
sedaris has  said when he is working all a problem
he never thinks about beauty but when
the problem is solved and the
solution isn't it isn't beautiful then
it's no good that's why beauty plays
a role but today it's not so
much
beauty and only flowers it goes in
first and foremost
science
the
big stage for science
kasten has already said we
invited three institutes these
institutes were given a task by us i chose
the
flowers and wanted to know
what comes to mind as if how can you
create a connection between the
flowers and yours  institute
i have here for the institute for the
waters
what is the name of the institute for
water ecology and inland fisheries like
the abbreviation
gb yes i gave it a piece of
grass that a sign here
reminds us of the china boss because i thought
it was near  water you can also
operate sewage treatment plants with such grasses
and then you might think of something
lag i  ch wrong
ok
soon is the institute for
crystal growth what is the name of this
institute is the leibniz institute for
crystal
growth strengthens and the abbreviation is
ekz that's exactly what i thought the
flower is quite okay for you because
crystals are also ice crystals
and sugar crystals and sugar  is a
waste of photosynthesis you
should also put a bit of sugar in the
water when you flower and the crystalline
form is maybe always looking for something floral
and the flower growers are particularly
proud am something graphic succeeds in
the breeding or did
i choose it that kind of a bit  music has
dice and also
ladies i was wrong
today offers help during the series he
is still a delphinium
larkspur i thought the farmer
people maybe have something to do with poisons
i heard that the dose makes
the poison and with larkspur by the way
Another tip you can kill your mother-in-law,
that's us  Klich
really poisonous but also little rabbits
and stuff and what does it have to do with your
institute we will experience a big
appearance this is the max
delbrück center for molecular pharmacology the
abbreviation is probably
mdc he almost thought it to me
is clever yes
yes  yes that's sort of the task who
spends a little time and
keeps trying to keep you entertained
and
not to
lose sight of science
we'd try that
now it's of course important how we
know where to start is not just in the
formula  1 run like that the pole position the
hottest position but
actually still everywhere in
the singers compete against each other yes who
performs first but
we didn’t want to just
give that away arbitrarily we wanted to play with
you there is a game there I ask you to get
up and up  the playground and
that's also a good opportunity for us
for a little small talk, first of all d  ie
rules and then chatting a bit
there are these discs here how does
a stick come or pushing it to a target point in the pool
is a bit like pool or
boccia in curling and whoever is
close won first place
first further under third three
attempts and  then let's go will
test a bit beforehand i'll give you the
queues do you actually have a micro he
no crown a bit of a pity but you
have a wonderful
i wanted to ask something so here
always thanks the playing
angeles roosevelt how much gimmicking is
hidden in your work if you do
proper research what role does
gimmick play gimmick has a very big
meaning for us they always say the
difference between research and play
is the protocol in the end
understand exactly and know that it's just a
saying or do you mean it seriously
you really like it a lot or are you
more of a type who have everything today
not someone who likes sp  ielt is
important with the researcher that you have
both types of people with you,
the ones who play and then the people who
then try to make something sensible out
of it. I belong to the first
category
running next stop
just a little bit interested
anyway do that maybe
you can answer that i think yes
if you get children with seven into
the topic there they are at a
most receptive are enthusiastic at 7
and what role does age play in
research when  should you start as a
child you found your zenith upper body on
[music]
i think we'll
start with fresh ones if he cut his
whole life too like with shortening or
do you stop earlier that the researchers say that
europe is like that too 60 years before
retirement here also makes biting  die
or researchers scientists work
until they die or go
on could also continue
hobbies like gemac  ht is ok i will
show that the game
so
you can choose your discs you have every institute
got a color and you can
choose here
[music]
how was it with this film was it
fun to create films
yes  definitely
we were able to really live it up in the
lab
it's a bit strange but we
liked
to do it in any case so all of a
sudden they also just with what fervor now that
the colleagues are working in the lab it's
also over comes in the film now the defense
very much  well there are yes i am happy yes
what i said game is yes
yes yes we are still working on the chance
or first of all six times i have
three armatix times i have three off
and i know
[music]
fact
and what they  always been in his
discipline or way so it has
other passions first so well i
would prefer something else and i
actually wanted to be a teacher biology first, i.e.
the biological part in the
foreground  i after that the
medical direction should maybe be more of a
doctor but i got stuck in
molecular biology and
that's fun for me every day
was like right now
science also plays a big role
your science probably also plays
a big role how was it  question
science plays
a big role right now it seems to me everyone is talking
about scientific topics and now
it's
your turn that's a type of sweat the other
way there actually just way yeah
ok what's allowed so that science is having
a big time right now isn't it  is
misunderstood now science has
always had a great time so the 20th
century is very extreme and the
twenty-first
will now be just as many children maybe want to become
scientists
because in times of pandemic they noticed
maybe where is right and I
hope also after this show  was still a
lot to notice
that we want to achieve so we have to  n
still playing there there you have because
they also say that many
scientists have come up with great ideas in their free time with
secondary activities
I expect the
bathtub has climbed
and Erika wrote I have there are also
anecdotes of such casualness I
didn’t find it  funny that was max
delbrück said that the dna is a stupid
staffing molecule so that the dna has
no function so that even
scientists sometimes have opinions
that are then revised afterwards
we know very well that the perpetrator is very
important for us
that's what he said  this hörbiger of
his world as a theory
that has been explaining to everyone for ages that everything is on
ice
have you
ever replaced
the government on the subject of flowers again do you have flowers in
your at your workplace
yes we have flowers at our place
and we  are fortunately in a four-
man office and there is always someone there
to take care of the flowers  some people
have green thumbs and others
a little less there are also flowers
can talk too
more
often what was the most beautiful
[music]
that the offer is pending because
where
is there again ice cream to the peaceful to
something we have now who is the first
blue blue is the first contribution green is
the second yellow far off
sometimes there is also different  he
remembered the last film more and the
first one was already forgotten so
we don't know honestly
we only made it possible for you to gain a bit of
time and wrested something from you in small talk
that you
might not have said if the officials here
weren't quiet  it says well
how does it look like you did it
really well we have the
rough order as the first film
we play  from the institute for
aquatic ecology and inland fisheries
secondly the films from the
leibniz institute for crystal growth
and thirdly the film from the
max delbrück center for molecular
medicine
ok
while the films are being played out
i activate the voting tool here
you give your devices the
internet capability
once www.cnty.com is on
and then
there are the numbers 15 35
57 24 i will repeat that again and again
www.cnty.com then we will play the films
with very short interruptions in
between so that we can remember
which institute we saw  and
when all films have been played then
the voting starts for 30 minutes ingo
will mark the ten minute sections on his musical instrument
with the help of a conventional egg
becker
and after 30 minutes the
word will be closed and we will look at
the results who will feel the winner
then from december mid-
december on the s1 facade of the paul
drude institute that is the
large facade between the concert
hall and the christmas market so a
very prominent place
i think we can start the films
then i will take you like chris if
you sit on the bench there you look on
intently we will start filming the
institute  for aquatic
ecology and inland fisheries
only later
does this
flower have a task here i am saying they
are everywhere
[music]
yeah
that can't have been the whole film
we have technical problems here
the advertising is usually shown here
with which we finance everything
it's a shame the pathogen will become  the
mobile phone is the nursery of the big new
streaming business big tv shows
are streamed live so we are very good looking at the
beginning
i
almost didn’t recognize them through these
masks but i recognize you by your glasses
then
[music]
please
[  music]
the technical problems are bigger than
we
could have hoped we play at the sc  oh
well let's play the film again and we'll
see how it affects the skin
we're going to play the film by the
institute of the leibniz institute for
crystal
growth flowers now my task
was hat
[music]
[  music]
thank you very much that was the film from the
max delbrück center for molecular
medicine
abbreviated mdc we need that later
in the voting now let's try whether
we the 5 is
crucial the film from the
leibniz institute for crystal growth
right now it's coming from the
mdc from the max delbrück center for
molecular medicine
please
[music]
it's
this
[music]
not
recognizr celebrated
[music]
thank you very much that was the film from the
mdc next we'll try to get
through the film from the institute for water ecology and inland fisheries from the igb again
first donor up  be higher
us
said this glass
[music]
euro
maybe she can
tell the film
we have a chance to see the film to the
end
doesn't work
okay we will play the igb film on our site
and we still wanted to over everyone  three
films and extrapolate before the beginning
of the film to the entire opus
again to the voting mechanism that
we use
mobile devices type in
[music]
www.cnty.com then you have to enter
four digits there and enter four digits again the
first four are
from now on voting is possible
www.ti.com
15 35
57 24 i see two people have
understood solutions to the 3 it seems to be so
welcome now we have 30
minutes to wait
everyone can vote if the
once you have voted you can't give any
more but we want to use the
time peacefully and i
talk to the institutes again but
maybe had to in between
the numbers are repeated from
time to time i like to do that too heat naked as numbers above
all let me remind you the mdc of the max
delbrück center for molecular medicine
is also the ekz is the
leibniz institute for crystal
growth the igb is the institute for
aquatic ecology and inland fisheries
yes maybe you can ask them again to
really tell the film
what where is the question what is
coming to us to take to the flowers
[applause]
[music]
the impact on a new builds on the
simyo activity cnet animated magazin
the reviews were
[music]
with comes to hot
contamination of the
[music]
system
inc
[music]
what interests me but you also
shot with underwater camera
it is lupo transfigure
highly recommend continue voting this one
has www.  ti.com the user code one 55
57 previously the institute again
[laughter]
[music]
I think I don't even have to
reach wa  s for the flowers get this
here, however, the clear no water
pushes the school quickly
without a browser
thank
you very much [applause] may you remember you can still
vote
www.bentley.com the code is 15 35 57 24
we just heard that eb
would like to be next  we talk
to owen ernst from
the company's leibniz institute for crystal growth will now see yes what
are you working on great
yes i will come i will come to the front to the
flowers there it is also much
nicer
i will work on it i have
to dig a bit further we have  yes seen
but first that's david henninger from
the film
so and david brought us something
and the workshop here has
spared no expense or effort
and planted a crystal in such a
granulate and
a crystal flower then grew from it, that's definitely
true  unfortunately almost in that
direction so the question what am I
working on we saw these ten
crystals in the video from the z
came out in the melt and you can see from that
crystalline materials are very much
dependent on the liquid form
they had before and i don't grow crystals as
large as we have seen now
but microscopically smaller
because i can only
see them under the microscope and can there  you don't
use such a big title now if you
grow from a
droplet, i.e. from a small droplet and i
deal with it, which
properties these small droplets
have in order to then pull out very small
crystals and the question that i
then follows is maybe a good one as you need
it  such small crystals with the big
ones one can well imagine
that it is quite simple that the small
crystals can sometimes act just as well
in technology as the large
crystals and of course use much
less material, so a lot of
resources are Spanish and that's that
what I'm dealing with I
remember  in my earlier
life i also pulled crystals there
were these little
cat hair like christa let visker
exactly we didn't want them exactly
we want them yes
that means what used to be seen as a dirt
effect the livestock is now
targeted and could therefore be special
effects yes i wouldn't
emphasize that we grow dirt effects
but if you want to put it that way
then yes
ok and the leibniz institute for
crystal growth is a service
institute or a research institute you grow crystals
for others who
do something with them you investigate  the
growth itself or
researched as well as the material as
well as that is very special about the
leibniz institutes and the motto is
theory akon praxis so both
theory and practice that means
we have gained a conglomerate
both provide this service stop
for other research for industry
partially produce crystals so that they
can be used there but
also to really do the
research on the material yourself our institute
spot or institute will be happy to accept
wafers from you on which we can then
grow and experiment other things we
have a close cooperation
what does your future look
like do you want  crystal growers remain
so i am very very satisfied with the
work atmosphere at the ekz with the topics
at the ekz and in general with the ekz and
that is why i would definitely like to stay there for the next few
years i
saw the director is there so it is
a bit  rice
[laughter]
but I also liked the film because it's
professional everything worked out great
will the singers' war I mean the
scientist
is from science on it but I
made such a great film there
we also had help with it so first of all
the camera team  what worked with
us then gave us a hand sends these
ingredients audience really great support
because of a scientist here from berlin
and yes we were also very satisfied with
the flower that we get private yes i
can't before we have many and
phoned different people who are familiar with
flowers to have them explain
to us what
kind of plant it is and which  flower language
flowers always have a language the
symbols and symbols symbolism for
bavaria it stands for
enthusiasm fascination and of course we were
very excited that we got
exactly this flower for today's event
our
fascination for science for
to show the crystal cultivation that it
works
the language of flowers works yes
that was very very well liked
well good advice showed
you are also good guys of course but he
was also given good advice from all sides
also that was done very well be
careful  how important is it that
you also communicate like this, I mean
actually  well we are in the science
community
father probably writes publications at conferences
why that why do we feel why
do you care and very
important a few years
ago the motto came up in science like
us that we need more data experts
and less dating  experts more out and
less good going on there was a
discussion in science and
i would speak up again because of
course we need science it
is very important but science
alone i can solve everything we
still need the society
behind it we need acceptance
society wanted to hear something from a
good 19 and it is not enough just
to produce a vaccination if a
large part of society
does not want to accept this vaccination, that means
this communication with society
is very important and also that we
scientists are not left to our
own devices  are but that we  because we
get help from people who know more
about it than we do and get us
out of our ivory tower a bit
so communication is very very important
we also thought that enthusiasm could be
very important that there is also
something why if it works
a kind of jubilation or his experience of the
transcendence of beauty that is
greater than everything and truer and
ewald beauty are there such moments in
your research where he says that's right
is unbelievable a great moment at
work yes of course there are in a
big way  well now that the
nobel prizes have just been awarded there is of
course great jubilation great fascination every time
but every scientist
has the little things with him
that he can really cheer about at least once in his
doctoral thesis, for example
that was great that
was great we in  the
crystal growing we always have a lot
to do with symmetry
and we are happy  whenever we
come out with only functionality
that comes from this symmetry so
pablo picasso or probably said symmetry
is the aesthetics of the primitive and
we don't emphasize that one
hundred percent but in fact
many things in science
only become interesting if you think out of this box
out of this out of this
symmetry if i doped for example it
would be in crystal
growing that you stop in this perfect crystal we also saw that in the video if you deliberately bring in
foreign atoms that i slightly shift the entire crystal lattice
maybe tense and only then
happens  this this miracle that
we can make technology out of it i
that reminds me of that is you said at the beginning
if something is true then
it's nice too he goes one step
further and says and then we still have
a little scratch on it and then
it will be  really interesting then
we look in the n  see nature more than before very precisely i would also be important that was his reputation can live properly not just like that but really with all his might and as I said also with these possibilities of a transcendent experience of his god-like so that art or science can we scientists we deal with miracles exactly we deal with nature we look at it very closely and a lot of it still seems like a miracle even if you have understood everything how you can conduct electricity in a semi-metal but once it starts to shine in the the most brilliant colors in green or red then i can personally describe it as a miracle even if we know exactly how it works so a certain heartbeat is part of it i know that from the laboratory at half past three in the morning are the results you want to tell then can't understand anyone away in the one thank you i think we have one
get an impression from you yes good will be
nice film by nice
leibniz institute for crystal growth
[applause]
let me remind you it can still be
voted on at www.ni.com the
code is 15 35 57 24
now we have another institute
sitting there  christoph rats probably from the
max delbrück center for molecular
medicine there was a
beautiful film absolutely
professional why why can you
do that i believe that we actually do all of
our work in the laboratory it really
is great teamwork with every piece of work
everyone is totally committed  for everyone
else it was and i think that also
reflects the spirit that elster wants to be reflected in the
research,
that it is on different so that
we are now working together both on a
national level and on an
international level to answer big or
serious
questions like  the coop 19 crisis for
example and gave it to us badly
managed that they did well from what i abe  r was
just impressed that you can
also communicate that kassel is
also cool in the audience
he's a ranger
we've already said that if
he continues like this we'll let each other
know Hollywood so the actors definitely have a
plan b if the research doesn't work
out exactly reveals the agent is  we will ask them
here too in a
moment
yes imparting knowledge is also important
how does it seem to me that you don’t get
more and more
lonely alone at your ivory tower and there are also
events like this do you think it
’s good or do you think it’s supposed to be the
debutants wasn’t  so that i
have a say and so they should
leave the scientists to themselves
or do you
seriously think i didn't have to
explain that it's important
to talk a bit about your work and
also so that maybe more people
understand it  as only the colleague I
find and since I give my rights in
above that the acceptance also getr
must be acted by a complete
society
and then there is also this trust
that we work according to principles
and integrity is maintained and i
think it is a matter of
course first of
all in the panel of experts that we discuss these molecular-biological basics accordingly or questions
ask and answer but then also
let the population participate in
our inventions, our innovations,
so that there
is also motivation for this relief
then for science or a
career in science
and after a trip, how is
it with abuse  you are afraid of the
tableau that was the rvr means the
results of your research also what
happens what you don’t want at all is
how how do you deal with it if you
sit there every day and work and think
actually you can do that too how
i like such a condition with the
beautiful  en larkspur you can make
your mother-in-law
you could definitely but
as scientists we have all
sworn that we really
stand for integrity and i think that is up to
each individual we take it
but i find for me
now that i can only work according to these principles
and principles work because
then the work can
also arise and that has also determined my
career because these great results,
some of which may be
fabricated by certain people, are short-
lived and I think if you
do solid work for a long time, then what
acceptance and  that's why he's not so
afraid of misuse he's not at all
fascinated and I'm also
incredibly critical so and I think
that's one of the most important
characteristics that scientists are
critical of their data,
the data of others, but still
even if it's proven  from
several that too  believe and
then define that later as a general dogma
after a bavarian i
think some very important points
have come together one is that
mediation is also important to the public in
order to
avoid misuse if you spread the knowledge
and then everyone knows it is  that is
much better than if the
secret knowledge is what is being spread somewhere
but then it also seems to me to be very
important that science is not
only good when it is popularly
explained is a trademark of the
ivory tower as much as science
can be extremely complicated and
extremely difficult to understand  and that
must also be possible
you described these mechanisms you check check again
actually
look for your own mistakes that's what makes science
so different than in english
where you say marlon research and mean
i googled it research a very
hard business the
most important difference
yet  go to him  umen maybe we
are standing here we are talking through the flower
i think the great thing was in the blood if
i also that the as natural
so here is what is natural but we
all know there are highly complex breeds
everywhere so is your kicks more that’s
all from people  so made a
great cultural achievement but
still has the i naturally have a
business with you in research is
it how natural is that or how
artificial i say that of course
that your own drive
to create something new and that the
knowledge base to  but now of
course also partly because
you say that you don't have to
bite your teeth and really have to look ok that
we'll publish that as soon as possible
that we'll have the most
diverse conditions at
the post office a lot of checks in
science and  it's sometimes
finally a bit tedious but it
's very important to then on to the
integrity of your
research results then also than about
others and so i would i would
say it is more fascination so even
if you are in the laboratory for twelve 13 hours
for me it is still not
when i go home i am
completely exhausted but really
What I did today was fascinating, but I
also found it is not
so natural every day, but it's then
maybe another two or three weeks that
will be a great result again
and then you're really happy that it
's like Easter Christmas together
birthday  maybe also from time to time
so
who really we gives you the
tasks we said before what you should
research on i believe that it
depends on your own drive to
find out something new but also now on
the possibility what
interests you because we have different ones there
now  called two, so I'm more
at home in immunology and
I find it easy to use them
freedom this creativity
that you can spend as a scientist is so
incredibly great because then
you are not stretched into a concept now
there costs of course you have to
work on certain things so i
am now also employed by my
boss with a fixed project but
you can  then within these
limits you can actually
move quite freely and bring in your own ideas
and as a
very creative person i find it
really exciting to work
out facts that you may
then later know or
hopefully of course and also knowing
is part of finding out
what is wrong then  can be placed on a
project check whether this
procedure works and you say
no with scientific curetis
exactly i think it
was also incredibly important that arguing in front of
the public now or certain
there are a lot of people who have
any half-truths dana  ch
trumpeted and how it
demanded scientists to work against it with
scientific arguments,
i.e. documents
of integrity, and say no, that’s not true,
they have because the evidence is so precise
and the discussion in the scientific
community is not proof that
something is uncertain  that something is
done seriously that differentiates it from
my beliefs and that
would be incontestable and therefore cannot be
true exactly
happy we have here for people but
I think I'm there they say but so close
because they but the appropriate I find
the films really very  very nice and
that you are there you also took it
seriously and briefly dealt with the topic of
flowers and then come back to
you when it's great we had
technical problems okay that's really
sad right now and the time is around 1
we know that now  voting we
can watch you freely
[music]
that worked technically,
you can  vote again that
's still machines
i would say let's show that
first friedrich co maria
mdc konzett dgb had
gone don't you want you want with the
camera
the mdc with
[music]
[applause]
institute for crystal growth with 18
percent  of the votes
[music]
and the institute for aquatic
ecology and inland fisheries
[music]
we are pleased to pay a fairly high
vote 230
votes have been cast which I think is quite good
in something more than wanted today in the room
above so that the technique with the
training worked
great show i would say that's a
bit small today will be lost
but i got all the flowers
here would you are at home on the
screen unfortunately can't
get any flowers for more besides its super
yes we were here in the prominent hall
here  is knut here you all want to be
we were here and
dealt with science thank
you very much dear people we dan  ken to all those
involved who were standing here
ingo günther on the hammond organ
[applause]
fritz & macziol for the
max delbrück center
[music]
now only for the leibniz institute for crystal growth
the films were produced by
[  Music]
tobias götz
with his cameraman giovanni and
i am very very happy that
liechtenstein with his knowledge of the
culture of the abysses of the floral he was
available here
[music]
[applause]
ok bye dear people at home
the monitors and calmly goes on
talking that will be something that was our already speaking the flower
yes
yes yes
[music]